euh on va passer à cette vidéo très
violente et très difficile à regarder
que c'est de cette jeune fille de 13 ans
qui a été très violemment agressée dans
le sous-sol d'un immeuble par quatre
jeunes filles vous avez tous vu cette
image certainement ici autour de la
table traîné au sol tiré par les jeeveux
insulé et roué de coup l'agression et
terriblement violente la vidéo filmée
par une complice a été énormément
partagée sur les réseaux sociaux il
diffusé en boucle sur les chaînes d'info
aujourd'hui c'est inadmissible bien
entendu c'est insoutenable de de
regarder ça et merci à mauis Bou euh du
coup journaliste police justice
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait c'est
quoi l'histoire alors faut savoir que
donc cette vidéo elle a été tournée le
10 octobre dernier donc elle remonte
quand même à 2 mois bien mais elle est
sortie que très récemment sur les
réseaux sociaux ces derniers jours en
fait et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs la
la procédure judiciaire a été accélérée
alors en fait le 10 octobre cette cette
c'est une collégianaère qui a 13 ans la
victime je peux pas donner son prénom
parce qu'elle est mineur elle est
protégée par la loi mais on va l'appeler
Lola elle est au collège et ce jour-là
et bien elle a un peu un mauvais
pressentiment elle sent quelque chose
chose se trame probablement par les
réseaux sociaux et elle d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'elle indique dans sa plainte elle
en parle à la directrice de l'école elle
sort des cours un peu avant 17h il y a
sa mère à la sortie de l'école qui
l'attend pour venir la chercher et elle
a une pseudo amie qui l'attend aussi qui
lui dit non viens viens avec moi on va
aller en ville ça va être sympa et tout
ça elle demande à sa mère qui finalement
accepte donc elle part avec sa copine
elle Prenn le bus elle voit que son ami
est échange beaucoup avec des personnes
sur son téléphone ça lui paraît bizarre
mais pas plus que ça et finalement son
ami prétexte euh de devoir recharger sa
cigarette électronique peuf pour
l'emmener dans une espèce de cave un
sous-sol et en fait qui se transforme en
getapant et c'est-à-dire que là c'est
une véritable expédition punitive vous
voyez les images elle se fait de
violenter de manière extraordinaire et
alors pourquoi elle se fait violenter ce
ce jour-là ça évidemment les questions
les policiers quand elle elle a porté
plainte de jours plus tard lui ont posé
la question et elle ce qu'elle dit c'est
qu'en fait elle elle aurait été agressée
sexuellement euh dans un bus par un
certain Yassine un jeune et euh elle
n'aurait pas voulu porter plainte mais
son père a dit il faut porter plainte et
donc en fait l'une de ces agresseur
qu'on voit sur la vidéo et la sœur de ce
garçon et on l'entend d'ailleurs elle
dit parle plus jamais de mon frère et
cetera et finalement on lui reproche et
bien d'avoir probablement terni la
réputation de son frère alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe en fait à la fin de cette
scène extrêmement violente les
agresseurs les filles là sont parties
elles sont quatre hein il y en a une qui
lui vole son téléphone deux qui la
frappe et une qui filme elles s'en vont
et là euh cette jeune fille Lola elle
est emmenée par sa mère à l'hôpital à
Bron aux urgences pédiatriques et ce
n'est bizarrement que de jours plus tard
c'estàdire que sa mère n'a pas porté
plainte mais c'est son père ses parents
sont séparés c'est son père qui de jours
plus tard l'emmène au commissariat pour
porter plainte pendant 2 mois il ne se
passe rien puisque finalement cette
affaire on en avait pas entendu parler
la justice n'avance pas et c'est
j'allais dire grâce à la diffusion quand
même de ces images sur les réseaux
sociaux que finalement en 24 heures tout
a bougé les quatre personnes les quatre
filles mis mise en cause ont été placé
en garde vue sont actuellement entendus
par la police et moi j'ai parlé au Père
ce matin au téléphone alors forcément
lui quand il me voit ses images il me
dit mais pour un père c'est horrible de
voir sa fille j'endors plus et cetera
donc si vous voulez il y a l'effet
pervers et en même temps bénéfique de
ces images c'est à la fois elles ont
permis ces images de faire avancer
l'enquête et d'attraper les les mises en
cause et de les les remettre au mains de
la police et en même temps elles sont
très dures pour cette fille pour toute
sa famille alors elle va comment
aujourd'hui la jeune fille bah ça je
sais pas alors moi j'ai parlé à son père
je sais qu'elle s'est exprimé hier soir
avec l'influenceur Bassem et elle a
l'air de elle a l'air voilà de lui dire
qu'elle est très blasée enfin on la sent
un peu dépité cette histoire elle
remonte à 2 mois donc en fait elle a dû
la digérer enfin physiquement elle a pas
de séquel elle a pas de alors elle a eu
si alors elle a eu un jour d'ITT ce qui
est pas beaucoup c'est les c'est les UMJ
les unités médicaujudiciaires si vous
voulez qui évalu le préjudice corporel
mais faut savoir que elle a pororté
plein 2 jours après et qu'elle n'est pas
n'est pas allé tout de suite voir les
unités médicaujudiciaaires donc en fait
ce un jour d'ITT n'est peut-être pas
forcément en adéquation avec les cooups
qu'elle a reçu le jour même donc en fait
donc là
il y a deux plaintes que il y a la
plainte des genre pour pour agression
sexuelle par le frère d'une des présumé
des adolescente suspecté et plus
derrière donc la plainte
pour alors il y a même une troisième
plainte en fait puisque quand cette
vidéo est sortie sur les réseaux sociaux
ces derniers jours et bien l'une des
filles qui est qui est mise en cause
dans la faire celle qui est d'ailleurs
allée la chercher à la sortie de l'école
est allée avec sa mère au commissariat
hier soir et a dit bah voilà depuis la
la publication de cette vidéo je suis
victime de menace de mort sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc elle s'est
présenté en tant que victime en faisant
ça forcément la police s'est dit bon bah
on tient une des suspectes et donc le
lendemain elle a été reconvoqué et
placée en garde à vue d'accord alors on
espère qu'il va y avoir quand même une
une sanction très très importante pour
ces quatre jeunes filles hein viment ça
serait Gill oui alors avec les mineurs
c'est par toujours il de minorité c'est
normalement la moitié de la peine mais
là effectivement vu la violence et la
vidéo est terrible parce que on voit la
jeune victime suppliez laissez-moi je
vous donne de l'argent pour que vous me
laissiez c'est terrible ces mots sont
terribles ça fait ça a cré ça a créé la
stupeur donc on espère une peine
exemplaire absolument mais ça veut dire
quoi une peine exemplaire en fait au
pire elles vont avoir quoi en fait elles
vont avoir rien non bah ça dépend ça
dépend de plusieurs choses ça dépend de
leur casier judiciaire est-ce que c'est
la première fois qu'elleelle frappe
quelqu'un voyez leurs antécédents en
fait la justice des mineurs d'abord
elles vont passer devant un juge qui va
dire c'est oui non oui ou non elles sont
compoupables bon ça va être assez facile
de déterminer leur culpabilité en
revanche ce qui va se passer après il y
aura une espèce de période probatoire on
va observer leur comportement si ell se
comporte bien à la fin il y aura une une
audience de sanction et là la sanction
va être adaptée à leur comportement
entre les deux donc si elle se comporte
bien pendant la période probatoire la
sanction peut être assez légère mais
elles sont quand même poursuivi je le
dis pour violence aggravée et menace de
mort réitérée c'est quand même des chefs
d'acusation il y a pas de centre
éducatif ferm par exemple si ça pourrait
là oui oui ça pourrait se substituer à
la prison parce qu'effectivement 13 14
ans il est très très improbable de
manière réaliste qu'elles aillent en
prison mais un centre éducatif fermé
pourrait être une sanction adapté à mon
faut trouver faut trouver une solution
faut arrêter de me faire croire que
maintenant c'est 18 ans la majorité faut
arrêter avec cette majorité à 18 ans un
mom de 16 ans c'est pas un mom de 16 ans
des années 50 maintenant il y a le
téléphone il y a la violence qui encore
plus plus barbare qu'avant on parle
d'une jeune fille qui s'est fait
tabasser parce qu' parce qu'elle a subi
une agression sexuelle compte le
cheminement et ils viennent il la
tabassent tous moi j'aimerais bien qu'un
moment donné on se penche sur les
parents à 13 ans qu'on arrête de dire
comment ça se fait qu'à 13 ans moi moi
moi je vois pas mes enfants à 13 ans
aller tabasser quelqu'un quand ils
avaient 13 ans on va parler d'éducation
un moment donné s'il faut taper sur les
parents faut dire à vos parents aux
parents élever vos enfants et il faut
arrêter de dire ah bah c'est des mineurs
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse et
ben c'est ces mineurs là ils ont des
parents donc à un moment donné il faut
aller chercher les parents élevez vos
enfants et c'est passage à Tabas là
juste parce que elle a subi une
agression sexuelle c'est insupportable à
la base elle se fait taper pour ça en
fait donc c'est un support portable et
moi j'en ai marre d'entendre ils ont 14
ans ils auront rien les momes de 15 16
ans c'est pas les momes des années 50 je
me répète c'est pas les mêmes personnes
faut attendre 18 ans pour la majorité
non mais attends et puis le message en
fait ça va être bah finalement quand
quand quelqu'un porte plainte contre
vous vous pouvez la faire taire regardez
en fait il suffit de tabasser quelqu'un
au pire qu'est-ce qui va vous arriver si
vous êtes un peu sage en gros c'est ça
si si elles font profil bas pendant
quelques temps elles vont elles V elles
vont être tranquilles et Ren AR et le
pire je dirais c'est plutôt que pendant
2 mois avant la publication de cette
vidéo sur les réseau sociaux il ne s'est
rien passé il n'y a pas eu d'enquête il
y pas eu de garde à vue l'enquête point
vous
imag le nombre d'hoire similair le
nombre d'histoir similair qui ne sont
pas filmé qui ne sont pas filmés et donc
des jeunes filles et des jeunes garçons
qui se font tabasser et qui n'ont pas de
preuve mais c'est à vomir parce que là
c'est des abrutis qui filment eux-mêmes
c'est les agresseurs c'est eux qui se
filment eux même si se filme pas c'est
rissime que ça soit filmoui eu même qui
se sont mais si la vidéo nétait pas
sortie ant
Mo qui l' sorti cette non mais moi ce
que je pense c'est qu'elle a dû circuler
dans des boucles vous voyez et ca et il
y a quelqu'un qui a dû l'avoir et qui ou
non qui a été quand même choqué et qui
s'est dit c'est
normals on d faire les Malines c'est des
abruti tot Bonot les
malè le problème qu'il y a je vais vous
dire c'est ça et et et et après c'est ça
qui fait qu'il y a des des
dérives c'est que à un moment il va rien
se passer pour
elle un paire moi je vais vous dire la
vérité moi tu vois ça truc en vrai il y
a plein de paires qui vont faut il faut
pas penser comme ça dire on va se faire
justice même et on va
attraper les équipes et ça va mal se
terminer et c'est ça qui va se passer et
on sait très bien sanctions ferm parce
que les
adresses
par règl les coordonnées les noms les
visages commencent déjà à tourner sur
les réseaux sociaux et s'il n'y a pas de
sanction ferme malheureusement et c'est
pas souhaitable mais il va y avoir des
des dérives des gens qui vont faire
justice même ça commence déjà à se dire
sur le Réau
mais regardez tous les gens là il y a
beaucoup de téléspectateurs qui me
disent Siri je peux pas regarder ça j'ai
envie de les taper oui alors que c'est
pas leur fill compte pas c'est vrai que
là tous quand on voit ça là on a plus
envie il y a une injustice c'est
terrible c'est des petites merdeuses
puisque quand elle se fa harcelé sur les
réseaux elle pleure à la police et-moi
et- moi je je suis menacé de mort en
plus de ça c'est des petites merdeuses
donc à un moment donné on s'en prend à
qui direuss qu'elle pas pris conscience
de ce qu'elle fait pas pris conscience
de quoi elle emè elle emmène une jeune
fille dans un gu ce que je te non mais
écoute-moi au lieu de hurler ce que je
te dis c'est qu'elle n elles n'ont
visiblement pas pris conscience Paris
que l'une d'entre elles qui est qui a
participé au forfait elle elle va le
lendemain enfin elle va dire à la police
regardez c'est je suis moi victime ça
veut dire qu'elle n'a pas compris
qu'elle était elle un bourreau comment
on peut espérer comment on peut espérer
que des filles comme ça
comprn des abrutis c'est que des mythos
et je peux te dire elles disent
maintenant qu'elles ont compris parce
qu'elles se sont faites convoquer que la
vidéo est sortie sinon elles auraient
rien compris du tout elles aurit
continué leur vie normale elles auraient
continué à faire ça mais le problème
qu'il a jeoui il a le papa il a une très
bonne réaction bravo à lui
euh je moi moi par et c'est pas bien de
dire ça moi ça m'arrive euh c'est je
sais que ça va être une autre ça va être
ça va être une autre affaire et voilà et
je suis sûr qu'ici voilà il faut pas
mais on le sait très bien et on est on
est on le sait Raymon le connais c'est
pareil que moi voilà et le fait que
certains aient envie de les taper
témoigne de la molaisse de la justice
parce qu'ils savent qu'il ne va rien se
passer si on savait qu'il y avait des
sanctions fermes et qu'elles all en
prison et Cera personne ne ferit rien
mais là on sait déjà qu'il va rien se
passer
bonne mais mais il y a aussi un vrai
problème d'éducation je sais plus qui
estce qui disait ça tout à l'heure
clairement c'est évident que les parents
des agresseuses c'est des parents qui
ont mal fait leur boulot parce que je
veux bien que parfois des adolescents F
des erreurs non mais je veux bien
parfois non non il y a quand même une
hiérarchie non je suis désolé a une
hiérarchie dans la gravité de ce quand
gamin ils font ça c'est qu'il y a un
problème les amisas pas peur de tes
parents je suis
désolé si j'avais été agressé à 13 ans
des gens j' mon père Fas ses cheveux tu
as ses cheveux dans les mains elle est
en train de te supplier d'arrêter és
part
pasmisur moi je vais vous rappeler
l'histoire est-ce que vous vous rappelez
du papa qui s'était vengé euh parce que
sa fille avait été
violé oui il est aujourd'hui c'est lui
qui a été poursuivi aussi he ou donc
voilà donc un moment euh qu'est-ce c'est
c'est c'est aujourd'hui tu as pas de
solution pour revoir la majorité alors
juste on sait pas l'âge en fait des des
agresseurs finalement on sait que la
victime elle a 13 ans on sait pas l'âge
des agresseurs elles ont probablement
elles sont mineurs évidemment mais moi
j'allais dire sur la responsabilité des
parents ça dépend si vous avez je
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que la justice
le considère quelqu'un qui est en
dessous de 13 ans en général il a pas de
responsabilité pénale parce qu'on estime
finalement qu'il est trop jeune mais
donc ça veut dire quand même que là les
parents ont plus d'influence sur cette
personne en revanche plus vous approcher
de la majorité en général plus vous avez
un libre arbitre qui est grand et
j'allais dire moins vos parents sont
responsables et plus c'est des choix
personnels et vous êtes responsabl on en
fait quoi de ces personnes on on fait
quoi je suis désolé il faut un centre
éducatif ferm faut mettre est que ça
sert à quelque chose ah oui attention là
vous avez quand même des travailleurs
sociaux qui peuvent entre guillemets
rééduquer des jeunes en extrême
difficulté ou des jeunes violents bien
sûr centre éducatif fermé c'est presque
c'est pas une prison pour mineurs
attention mais il y a beaucoup de
contraintes il les réduque à la place
des
parents pour les rééduquer que les
parents a d faire
d
raonème prendre g dans par toi c'est
bien ce qu' dit mais lui c'est encore la
loi c'est bien ce qu' dit c'est la loi
on les on les prend on les met dans un
centre avec d'A d'autres débiles comme
eux ils restent entre débil entre entre
gens qui foutent le bordel après quand
ils ressortent c'est toujours pareil un
moment donné tu dis aux parents e tu as
fait un enfant il a 10 ans il a 12 ans
il a foutu le feu à une poubelle il a
tapé sur des pompiers il a tapé sur des
policiers il a agressé maintenant c'est
toi qui va aller devant le
tribunal ben ça devrait exister il me
gonfle ver fait pas des enfants pour les
Laer faire N
cy si je peux per non moi ce que je
pense le le plus grave pour l'avenir
c'est que je sais pas si vous voyez
comment fonctionne le harcèlement
scolaire mais en général les enfants
c'est c'est le problème de cet engrenage
c'est que quand un enfant est est
agressé comme ça et devient une tête de
turc au lieu d' d' tirer si vous voulez
la sympathie ou l'empathie des autres
élèves ça peut devenir au contraire
quelqu'un qui est encore plus voilà
voilà attaqué agressé encore plus ciblé
et et une cruauté comme ça qui se
développe parfois dans dans M exactement
et c'est ça le problème c'est c'est de
voir qu'est-ce que va devenir cette Lola
est-ce que dans son collège elle va
pouvoir avoir une scolarité normale
enfin comment ça va se passer pour la
suite pour elle après l'agression de
cette jeune fille là par ces quatre
barbares il y en a qui disent qu'il y
avait aussi les les frères de ces jeunes
filles qui l'attendaient alors
effectivement ce qu'elle raconte Lola
dans sa plainte c'est que il y a un
groupe de de garçons elle d'ailleurs
elle cite un des prénoms mais c'est pas
celui qui l'aurait agressé sexuellement
mais un groupe de garçons qui l'ont qui
les ont suivi jusque dans le sous-sol
quand ça s'est passé elle est sortie du
sous-sol euh les garçons étaient là à la
sortie et par contre ils sont allés
récupérer son téléphone portable
effectivement nettoyer pour vérifier
s'il y avait pas des choses ça je sais
pas mais en tout cas je sais qu' ils ont
fait entre guillemets cette démarche
d'aller chercher le téléphone qu'est-ce
que tu
penses mais que la justice fait pas trop
son
r Je suis d'accord
avec très pas avec tu peux pas être
d'accord avec non non
pas oui ou vraiment parce que c'est vrai
qu'il faut sanctionner moi-même j'ai un
garçon qui est adolescent si ça arrive
je pense qu'on a envie de faire justice
ce soi-même c'est ça c'est pas ce qu'il
faut faire parce queprès c'est
qu'rire qu' faut faire fa faire arr
faire pe faire on peut
pas c'est ce qu'on a dit pour les
squatter et ce on a envie de faire
justice soême par
queut
faireich qu' fallit faire plus plus vous
savez l'explosion des refus d'obtempéré
aujourd'hui en France il y en a plus de
25000 en fait c'est juste incroyable
mais en fait c'est parce que à la fin il
risque rien en fait c'est pour ça qu'il
ref d'obtempéré si on risquait quelque
chose après avoir un fait un refus
d'obtempéré peut-être qu'il y en aurait
beaucoup moins problème c'est ce laxisme
là quoi c'est plus possible plus
possible une question pour Raymon je
peux lui poser une question ouais moi tu
peux me poser question d'accords c'est
quoi ta question on n peut plus la
Mélenchon c'est pas du tout ça on peut
plus vasy ma P pose ta question Ron il
disait il faut attraper les parents tu
as dit ça il faut attraper les parents
alors voilà je vous la pose à vous deux
VO qu'est-ce que tu veux nous poser ça
veut dire ah c'est différent mais ça
veut dire quoi attraper les parents vous
voulez que les parents aillent en prison
à la place des enfants vous voulez des
enfants tu veux tu veux quoi mais c'est
Mo tu vois bien que tu as jamais les
solutions à rien toi tu vois bien que ta
France elle est elle est morte tu vois
bien que tout ce que tu dis c'est des
trucs 20 ans tu vois bien que tu es dans
l'échec tu vois bien que tu es dans la
spirale de l'échec tu le vois bien tu le
vois vous POS une question mais non vous
posz une question il respecte la loi en
tout cas oui bien s une question tu le
vois que tu es dans lapirale de l'échec
ou pas et ben moi je le vois je peux
dire tant mieux mais dire moi j'en ai
marre d'entendre 13 ans il va aller en
centre de
ri je veux convoquer les parents et je
veux mettre les parents devant la
justice même si c'est pour un rappel à
la loi même si c'est pour prendre une
peine de prison avec surcil qui vont pas
en prison parce que je dis pas les
parents les parents même si c'est 3 mois
de prison avec surcil les parents pour
que les parents quand ils rentrent le
soir qui regardent leur fils ou leur
fille dans les yeux si tuas vu tu m'as
emmené au tribunal parce que exactement
se isol leants se battent pour que leurs
enfants so se Bent pour punir leurs
enfants quand ils font des choses pas
bien il voi ça il dis moi en fait je me
casse le cul je vais bosser le matin
poursses tout
[Applaudissements]
seul de vitess c'est de vitesses ton
truc toi tu ve laisser les par agressurs
avec des Pistols à comm mais par va
acheter des pistolets à non mais sauf
que parfois ça peut être la double peine
vent quand tu dis ça parce que tu as des
tu as des parents qui sont simplement
dépassés par les événements et donc tu
leur rajoutes un truc en plus la plupart
du temps ils sont pas dépassés par les
événement vous prenez des cas les juges
ils sont pas bêtes quand ils auront des
parents en face d'ux qui VO un moment
isolé qui
galè oui mais ça n'existera jamais si on
fait rien mais le jour où on verra
quelqu'un de ta famille se faire Taber
tu verras comment ça fait bizar le seul
problème dans ce que tu dis c'est que
les enfants ils vont continuer c'est pas
parce qu'on vair les parents que les
enfants V continuer qu'il faut faire
qu'il faut faire moi je pense que les
parents sont responsables mais ce faut
faireir les en tu sais ce que j'ai fait
moi une fois vol j'ai volé la
coopérative à l'école au lycée j'ai volé
la coopéra mon TR je me suis fait taper
au lycée devant tout le monde par mon
père'ant tout le monde mon père j'ai
jisom moi je vais t'expliquer peut-être
ça marchera
pas ça marcher à 80 %
C on qu Mme peur de les par
on tu mets une San par et tu vas taper
portefeuille des
[Applaudissements]
par va dire ta connerieelle m'a coûé
1000 boules tuas
mais non plus
que dis prison j'ai pas dit en prison
c'est fa en prison il est jamais sorti
de ma
bouche le mot prison n'est jamais sorti
j'ai dit tribunal responsabilisé et 3
mois de prison avec surc j'ai jamais
parlé de
prison fa une grosse am pour
les le rappel à la
loi
le la plus grosse plaisanterie la plus
grosse plaisanterie c'est le rappel à la
loi mais qu'est-ce le rappel à la loi je
lu fais fa qu'est-ce qu'on a fout rappel
à la loi on s'en fout dis moi je te dis
moi je te dis le père de famille il est
au boulot la police elle arrive sur son
lieu de travail venez on va vous
interroger parce que votre fils il a
tabassé une petite fille dans une cave
tu vas chercher le père à son travail tu
vas voir si quand il rentre le soir il
dérouille pas son fils tu m'as foutu la
honte devant tous mes collègues les FLI
qui sont venus
chercher dire il a an dans la finale de
l'échec on se retrouve dans un instant
les chér et Guillaume j'ai une petite
surprise pour toi dans un instant dans
un instant il y a une surprise il y a
Ouriel qui vient
fr elle vient elle arrive dans un
instant avec enzou tout de
suite